a lot happens when an inflated rubber
ball hits the ground the rubber
compresses and quickly stamps back to
its round shape that snapping back makes
the ball bounce in addition the air
inside the ball acts as a tightly coiled
spring increasing the rebound when an
inflated rubber ball falls to the ground
it bounces back and players catch it on
the rebound
this type of ball is at the heart of
many games from basketball to soccer to
volleyball at the core is an inflated
rubber bladder making it starts with the
sheet of natural rubber the factory
worker folds it in a specific
configuration he places a dye on top and
activates a press to force it through
the layers which cuts out the shape he
now has the bladder of a sports ball he
brushes an adhesive around the hole in
the bladder and inserts a plug
another worker inflates the rubber
bladder as she places it in a spherical
chamber it heats and cures the rubber
for five minutes at a temperature of 284
degrees Fahrenheit the rubber bladder
spins on a revolving cylinder causing it
to take up nylon threads the threads
twist around the bladder and form a
layer that both strengthens it and keeps
it round the material that will form the
exterior of the ball is made using
colored synthetic rubber
natural rubber magnesium carbonate and
mineral oil once it cures a worker rolls
it into thick sheets and slices it to a
specific width he folds it several times
this blue rubber will be used for
volleyballs the folded rubber now
travels between a series of rollers they
flatten it and press it extremely thin
and it becomes both lightweight and
formable an automated blade slices the
rubber into shorter pieces a metal
pattern cutter will now be used to cut
the rubber into strips which will fit
together to form the outside of the ball
these particular strips are for a
basketball the worker places the pattern
on several pieces of rubber a press
forces the sharp edge pattern through
the rubber to cut out fish shaped strips
that are designed to fit around the
round bladder
[Music]
she lines the two halves of a bonding
chamber with the strip's she inserts the
bladder and reinflates it she closes the
bonding chamber and activates it inside
heat and pressure caused the strips to
stick to the bladder to make a medicine
ball which is used for exercising a
different pattern cutter is used the
forming process is the same but this
ball has a unique visual impact very
different from that of the basketball
[Music]
back at the basketball station a worker
applies the brand name to the outer skin
in two places glue helps the decal stick
to the rubber this mold will now
transfer a pattern onto the rubber ball
while also baking the lettering into it
another worker places the ball in the
mold and pumps more air into the bladder
he closes the lid the mold applies heat
and pressure to emboss the pattern onto
the rubber the lettering has penetrated
the rubber and the worker peels off the
decal plastic another worker replenishes
the air that's been lost to make the
ball completely full and round the ball
is now ready to receive its stripes the
worker paints black rubber into grooves
that were formed during embossing this
rubber quickly cures to become part of
the ball another worker inserts a fill
valve into the hole then mechanical
fists squeeze the ball to deflate it
this prepares it for packaging
with the valve inside it can be easily
reinf lated by the customer
a worker wraps it in plastic and ships
it to the retailer making this rubber
basketball has only taken a couple of
hours but it should be able to take a
lot of knocks and bounce right back